hello i'm julius and
i'm the owner of phone fix craft so
today i'm going to show you how i
clean and repair a damaged iphone my job
is
actually phone repairs including micro
soldering and data recovery stuff like
that
and the cleaning is just it's not that
it's a
huge part of our business it's just
fixed phones that we
see that they need they need some
cleaning
so the first step you have to remove
those two bottom screws
which every iphone has we opened up the
screen
the phone had a broken screen and the
owner of this phone used
used it for a good while with that
broken screen so that
all the internals of the phone were
exposed to whatever
was in customers pockets so
it's actually a fire hazard so so we try
to remove
every loose bit from from the inside of
the phones
but once it's loose i would use
compressed air like
like a gun
the dirtiest parts would be the charging
port
on on all kinds of phones not only
iphones
but actually it doesn't look dirty if
you
just look at it with naked eye and the
microscope i have
here is it's my most loved tool
it's gonna come come with me when i die
i will just clean every phone every
speaker every earpiece and every
charging port
under this this microscope this tool we
use for
charging port cleaning is something
similar to
a metal toothpick it's just a little bit
thinner and then
sharper so now i'm going to clean years
worth of pocket lint and just from the
charging port that experiencing charging
issues
the charging ports would be usually
filled with the
like pocket length uh from your from
your jeans and then
whatever is in your pocket really if you
had a cookie there
then you would have some crumbs or
something like that you can see you know
what
what color uh uh treads trousers or
pants i'm not sure
in in united states trousers or puns
so what you see here it's actually the
contents of uh of the charging port of
what we usually would find
there so it's a it's just a pocket lens
really pocket lint and
and dust
i would use the same tool that i use for
cleaning charging ports to clean the
really heavy clogged speakers as well
we do get phones that are really dirty
and messed up but
it's for us it's just normal you know
medics are not not surprised by
injuries or something like that it's
their job so
so for us it's uh yeah
so on this phone the battery has already
started to swell
and and customer agreed to get it
replaced we removed the battery
uh we attached the new pull tabs
to to a new battery
we just need to apply a new display
adhesive before
putting everything back together
so once the screen is pressed back into
the frame uh we just need to
put the last two screws in and it's it's
ready to be cleaned before giving it
back to the customer
you just have to solve solve a puzzle
you know to get the thing working
and this is especially rewarding if
some few other shops deemed it unfixable
and then it comes to you and and you
accept the challenge and you actually
get that fixed it's
uh it's nice it's uh that's what i
really love